everyone has been wondering what are we
going to do now that Game of Thrones has
completed its run well we have the
answer for you it's called The Witcher
and we're joined by the cast today Henry
Cavill Freya Allen and Daniel autre I
did pretty good right yeah I did pretty
good we're so excited to have you so
this show has so much already buzzing
about this is your new binge worthy show
this is the new sort of one that you're
gonna be watching are you guys prepared
for what is about to happen to your
lives I'm gonna answer for them
absolutely not there is a way to prepare
I mean it's it's almost an exciting run
to get up to this but yeah once once
this hits goes and everything changes
and now this is you you're gonna be your
comic-con before the storm as you say
have you gotten a chance to enjoy every
anything have you seen anyone out on the
streets have you been able to not at all
yeah we are so opposed to have actually
someone dressed up as geralt and
yennefer in our costumes that we even
within those photos that we released
yeah so that was pretty exciting and it
was it's amazing and they looked
incredible so everyone is talking about
your luck even in the very quick trailer
that we saw the look and then the drink
the wig tell me all about coming up with
your look well yeah okay
we had the description in the book and
Lauren and I went through many
conversations by email and phone before
we even met for the third time because
we had a first meeting dinner audition
and then we saw each other on set or
application on location um we were just
it was all about eyes and hair and the
hair took a long time to get the wig
right which took some amazing work by
Jackie who does all my hair does my
and it was it was tricky we had to get
the skin tone right as well and Alva who
does my makeup worked really hard on
that and just found that right balance
and we went through plenty of tests as
you may have seen nice I know you saw
one of them and we finally settled on
something which I think we're already
happy with what's it like when you're in
your trailer and you're done and you
look in the mirror and you're in that
costume it's really cool badass
definitely crosses your mind I mean and
wearing the contacts was was one thing
you had to wear for three hours at a
time and then take him out yeah and so
it was like I look really badass but my
eyes are a little bit human but it
definitely hope you get into character
yeah when you're wearing all that gets
up it's it's just a short step to get
all from that funniest moment on set so
far filming biggest in this hat there
was I film I didn't mind her and he is
so funny
and I remember doing the transformation
scene with him and my goodness like I
could have walked out of that day
feeling very depressed but because I had
him on set it was hilarious
keeping the mood light yet is it so
funny to be in between takes and be like
ha ha ha I find that really challenging
but you know actors work very you know
different actors work very different so
that's exciting as well it just brings a
new energy on set yeah really knows have
you had anything yet there was one day
where we had to spend the whole day just
sitting in front of this table
and have this disgusting meat on it
which will really smell and it's just
one of those bizarre days and and the
actor who plays iced he couldn't
pronounce this one word more hog and he
and every tape he was just like I just
can't get that right and he just was
like what am I even saying and we all
just couldn't stop laughing at the fact
he just didn't know what he was talking
about and the smell of me is just me
yeah as well no doubt you know Henry you
have said that you may be in the best
shape of your life this is crazy because
you're also Superman so I feel like
Superman was probably like the best
shape like how is it possible to be
better than Superman um well it's hard
every time you get into shape before I
get to shape for a movie or a TV show
it's always trying to upgrade from the
last one and my trainer Dave Rienzi is
absolutely fantastic and he he pushes me
to the point where it's the absolute
maximum for that job and then in the
interim between jobs we'll try and work
to improve it and then on the next job
again just try and push the envelope a
little more and so yeah each time if I'm
doing it right I should be in better
shape in theory how can you tell you're
in better shape
like you just benchpress more you can
like pick up more trucks it's all based
on uh yeah trucks I can pick up it's uh
no it's because we are working in a
medium of film yeah it's all about the
aesthetic and it's how one looks and so
if one looks a certain degree better
than you look previously and some people
won't notice a difference but people
like myself and Dave do because we're
we're going through the finite process
of changing things but yeah that and
also your fitness I do a charity run
every year the dollar challenge and it
gets easier every year and so
it's also a good way of measuring it
guys get heavier every year as well so
it's a good sign so on my off day I'll
eat like a deep-dish pizza
what's your like you know when you're
off off yeah it is if you say like a
vegetable dish no no no no no absolutely
not no I I go I go crazy when I have I
have a cheap meal Oh pouchy day
okay what's the meal um it is often
pizza he does it go to
but burgers are really good one and
sushi can be a good one too because you
can eat just vast amounts of it and it
when you compare it to what I normally
eat it's interesting okay I know sushi
is only consider a real big bear so it
has been reported that you didn't
immediately land this role right Lauren
who's here Lauren she they actually
passed over you for the first they were
like no thanks and then so what is the
process of you landing this well ie when
I heard they were making the Richard I
obviously was incredibly excited and I
annoyed the living daylights out of my
agents and I kept I call him every day
and said guys now meeting now how about
now and they eventually said look
they've brought on a showrunner and
we've called them and they said look
we're not even close to that process yet
and I kept on pushing pushing pushing
eventually I think Netflix has got tired
Lauren so I was like okay fine we'll
meet the guy and i'm if i sat down with
lauren we had a great conversation about
about the show where was going and and
my passion for it as well and and then
she was very frank with me the time said
look we haven't even started the process
of casting yet it was great to meet you
but we've got a long way to go yeah I've
got to start writing as well and so it
was then I think was a full month break
or something after that and it was I was
just hoping that when they came around
all the other casting and everything and
it's important that the right casting
process is done you can't just hire the
first person who walks into the room and
I was fortunate enough to land the role
and
after my audition which was was fun it
was it was nerve-wracking obviously
because I really really really wanted it
yeah but got there at the end and Here I
am now and so what's I like in the
hallway when there's like all the other
guys that are up for the same role as
you and you're staring them down and
you're like you don't even know me I've
been calling there thankfully thankfully
I did not have to go to that process it
was because they were right at the end
of their casting process and they said
to themselves I'm sure something more
lines of let's bring Henry and just hear
him read and see what he has to do and
at the time wasn't on holiday of Florida
and actually it was quite a big story
about cow that particular night before I
left to fly to New York to have this
meeting but yeah I got zero sleep that
night because of what happened to Gale
and then he had the audition and it went
well but it's just me I just flew into
New York - yeah I love that okay so we
talked about it a little bit but filling
the void of Game of Thrones a lot of
people like everyone on the planet is
saying this is the this is what all the
millions and millions of Game of Thrones
fans are going to move over to do you
feel I haven't watched Game of Thrones
so I can't comment but I do feel like
The Witcher is something it's we've
created a whole new world and there's a
lot of magical elements in in this world
that I don't think Game of Thrones has
so yeah it's it's it's something
completely different and if the fans
want to compare the two and yeah then
that's very flattering right it's it's
its own show yeah and it it has
obviously it's the genre fans
but there's a lot of prominent themes
that aren't necessarily as prominent in
gamma forever I think it's best to look
at it is it's not compare what's the
best way to watch so we have we live
tweet shows we have watch parties where
we dress up in full costumes and not
saying that I do it every week but you
know this happens so what are you
suggesting to your fandom
is the best way to watch the show cool
guys choose yeah full cost me hunt
amazing yeah I thought and oh sweet you
and Instagram you and you'll see it and
alright last thing before we bring
Lauren in because she's here and I want
to hear from her about this casting
process I know that during Sherlock
Holmes you worked with Milly Bobby Brown
and I'm wondering if there's any chance
that they you will pop up on stranger
things i Netflix I I don't know I mean
if there's a role which is I'm suited
for maybe and I'm the right guy for it
then there's a chance wasn't like
working with her she's incredible she
really is she's an absolute character
fantastic actress and I haven't finished
the job yet I'm still working on it and
I'm looking forward to the next day's
shooting with her yeah yeah
extraordinary Vegas do you want stranger
things but I have a feeling it's gonna
be very very busy there's a lot going on
all right let's bring in your EP this is
Lauren come on in you're gonna switch
seats with Henry there because he's you
it's wall it's so nice to see you hey so
tell me about this casting stitch when
did you first hear from Henry's annoying
agent really really early before we had
a script before we were casting before
we really knew anything about the show
okay no no that went lying yeah no
definitely not um no you know casting
Henry casting onion and Freya was all
like each of the casting processes is
really different
you've heard about Henry's already Anna
was actually the first person that we
cast and it was incredible because I was
flying back and forth between London
where I was in the writers room her Los
Angeles to London and I think you were
sort of pre-screened by Sophie
and then we went in and read Aniyah and
there was the scene that we have written
we had fake sides basically because we
knew they were going to leak yeah so I
went ahead and said like these are not
real singing Oh sneaky and but there was
a scene where yennefer was eating an
apple
and eating and I'm kind of getting
grossed out and do you remember we went
through how many apples
we were so many apples and there was a
point in the scene where and it would
take up under the Apple and then spit it
out everywhere and was like wiping it
off her face and we would finish the
seed and then and it would scramble
around and pick up all the chewed up
pieces of Apple be translated it's okay
you can be in it vide was such a great
it was such a great sort of indicator of
how beautiful we wanted I think into the
character yeah and then you know casting
Fran is Siri Siri was a really tough
casting process and we actually started
by looking at someone much much younger
Siri in the books is around 11 yeah and
we started there and very quickly we
sort of aged up the process but what's
great about Freya is she was actually
cast as another role at first a much
much smaller role in the first episode
and when we hadn't found our Syria yeah
we had seen over 200 girls and we hadn't
found our Siri and Sophie Holland our
casting director said I want I want you
to think about Fran for this and I
remember saying how are we gonna call
phrase agent and say we know we cast you
it's not that we don't want you for that
role but we may want you for something
slightly slightly bigger and I flew into
London and we met and and castrated that
day so that each of these processes were
totally different but like okay you guys
it's amazing last thing before you have
to go when Henry at the end is pulled in
for the final audition after he has been
like I'm so passionate you've met or
whatever did you have it in the back of
your mind like this is our guy or were
there others real contenders where
you're like it's um it's funny you know
so it was you can be honest yeah I mean
right behind you
you know what's funny and Henry actually
knows this is that after our first
meeting we met with tons of other
potential gerelds and by that point I
was writing a lot of the scenes and I
always had Henry's voice in my head so
when we finally when I finally said will
you come in and actually like read me
some lines so I can actually hear your
voice not just in my head when when
Henry left the day that day it was
myself and Sophie holiday now let's hack
her off our director and we'd all just
looked each other and smiled and we knew
it was done it was them telling each of
these rules was that day we knew we had
it
so it's auditioning the auditioning
process is nerve-racking it's never come
you never feel like you've nailed it oh
it's because you're in a room when you
want it more and more every every time
how many times did you come in three
times three times yeah Wow
well listen congratulations to all of
you get ready it's gonna be a ride we're
so happy and thank you for taking the
time at comic-con to come sit down with
Entertainment Tonight and give us some
insight into the way the show went
together can't wait to see it and good
luck thanks